Next, we'll be downloading IntelliJ,
which makes running programs easy.
IntelliJ is a development environment which is just another name for
an application that has extra tools that help us edit and run code.
Most developers use a development environment like IntelliJ to help them create,
compile, and run programs.
All of our programming examples and videos will be done using IntelliJ.
So we suggest that you use this environment too.
But if you already have some experience programming
and want to use another environment, that's okay too.
Just keep in mind that a different environment may
have different features and probably a different look.
Also, most software like IntelliJ and the Java Development kit
that it uses will include updates and will change over time.
So I recommend watching the installation videos to get an idea of the process.
And then for the most up-to-date and complete instructions,
check the text instructions that follow each video.
I'll walk through to how to download and install IntelliJ for Windows and Mac,
so click the option that's most suited to you to go to the correct video.